über all diese fragen wollen wir
sprechen ich freue mich sehr dieses tun
zu können mit georg maier von der spd
seines zeichens innenminister von
thüringen und erster stellvertretender
vorsitzender der innenministerkonferenz
guten tag herr meier
schönen guten morgen herr man ja wir
haben es gesehen menschen politiker sind
von rechter gewalt bedroht aber auch es
gab wahnsinnig viele todesfälle also
allein vom juni 2009 10 bis februar 2020
sind 13 menschen durch rechtsextreme
gewalt gestorben das ist mehr als in den
fast 14 jahren die der nsu aus dem
untergrund getötet hat wie erklären sie
sich diese eskalation rechter gewalt
naja das ist jetzt nicht aus dem nichts
gekommen sondern da gibt es eine
vorgeschichte rechte strukturen sind
über jahrzehnte muss man sagen gewachsen
und wir müssen uns die frage stellen wie
konnte das geschehen warum hat man zu
lange weggesehen
also ich denke mal mittlerweile ist
bewegung reingekommen ihn auch im
politischen bereich was ist alles zu tun
um gegen rechtsextremismus jahr und wir
müssen ja auch über rechts terrorismus
sprechen zu tun ist und es ist jetzt
einiges in bewegung gekommen aber wir
müssen weiter sehr viel darüber
diskutieren und handeln das ist ganz
wichtig schauen wir mal auf ihr
bundesland an der spitze der afg in
thüringen
da sitzt die röcke sie bezeichnen ihn
selbst ich darf sie zitieren als
spiritus rektor also die treibende kraft
auch der neue rechten bewegung
wie weit geht er in die vernetzung der
afg in die rechtsextreme szene ihrer
einschätzung nach also die fdp ist eine
partei die aus meiner sicht dazu
beiträgt dass rechtsextremistisches
gedankengut weiter einzigen kann in die
gesellschaft und das passiert ja auch
gerade jetzt corona demonstrationen
corona leugner verschwörungs mythen auch
dort trägt die afg dazu bei
zu mobilisieren zu diesen
demonstrationen und sie trägt auch dazu
bei dass diese verschwörungs mythen die
teilweise antisemitischen hintergrund
haben rassistischen hintergrund haben
weiter verbreitung finden das nennt man
entgrenzung und das ist ein phänomen was
nicht nur die afg natürlich vorantreibt
sondern auch neue rechte bewegungen der
dritte weg die identität bewegung und so
weiter das sind alles strömungen die
dazu beitragen dass das weiter in die
gesellschaft ein sieg hat und das macht
das problem aus wie gefährlich schätzen
sie die rechtsextremen netzwerke in der
polizei oder auch der bundeswehr ein
also wie aktuell haben wir auch den fall
vom ksk also hier darf es null toleranz
nur geben wir in thüringen sind hier
sehr konsequent hinterher um rassisten
in unseren reihen einfach zu
identifizieren und dann auch zu
entfernen es kann nicht sein dass
rassisten sich in sicherheitsorganen
befinden
und auch hier ist natürlich auch auf
bundesebene noch mal sehr viel mehr zu
tun genauer hinzuschauen wo hat sich
rassistische ideologie wo haben sich
rechtsextremistische wo hat sich recht
rechtsextremistisches gedankengut in
sicherheitsorganen verbreitet das ist
der blick auf sicherheitsorgane auf und
ist es ja häufig sind der fall dass wir
nach attentaten nach einem starken start
nach einer starken sicherheitspolitik
rufen das ist absolut verständlich aber
wie eben auch in dem beitrag angeklungen
trägt ja auch die gesellschaft eine eine
vereine verantwortung
wie würden sie diese beschreiben also
diese verantwortung dass tatsächlich
rechtes gedankengut rechtsextremes
gedankengut auch schon in der mitte der
gesellschaft angekommen ist wie es ihre
wahrnehmung da also es ist ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem es ist
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
herausforderung wir in thüringen haben
sehr gute erfahrungen gemacht indem wir
sowohl die repression also die arbeit
jetzt der polizei und des
verfassungsschutzes gestärkt haben aber
auf der anderen seite auch die
prävention
und wir haben sehr gute erfahrungen
gesammelt in der zusammenarbeit mit mit
bürgerforen mit demokratie gruppen wir
arbeiten eng zusammen wenn es zum
beispiel darum geht auch rechts
rockkonzerte das war das problem hier in
thüringen mit einer großen anzahl von
teilnehmern
das haben wir gemeinsam geschafft
zurückzudrängen verwaltung gehörten
sicherheitsorgane und demokratie gruppen
demokratiebewegungen zusammenzufinden
dann sind die erfolgsaussichten am
größten
die jahresbilanz 2020 zu rechter gewalt
und rechtsextremismus sie wird heute
vorgestellt von verbänden von
betroffenen und initiativen betroffene
und hinterbliebene von rechtsextremer
gewalt die haben oft das gefühl vom
rechtsstaat in stich gelassen zu werden
wie was entgegnen sie diesen vorwurf
dieser kritik da müssen wir besser
werden
ich habe mit kontakt auch mit
angehörigen der opfer
von hanau und was die bemängeln ist dass
der rechtsstaat einfach an der stelle
auch nicht empathisch ist dass man nicht
wahrnimmt wie es den menschen geht was
es mit ihnen macht und ich glaube dass
wir sind herausgefordert auch von seiten
jetzt der polizei dass wir andere
herangehensweise auch mit opfern haben
wissen sie hier in thüringen mehr als
die hälfte der opfer haben eine
migrationsgeschichte
wir haben in thüringen auch starken
anstieg der antisemitischen straftaten
und das sind wir eben aufgefordert nicht
nur diese straftaten zu bekämpfen
sondern auch mit den opfern den dialog
zu führen gemeinsam zu erarbeiten was zu
tun ist um sie besser zu schützen
das ist auch eine aufgabe der polizei
den schutz für diese gruppen zu
verbessern
vielen dank georg maier innenminister
von thüringen und erster vorsitzender
oder stellvertretender erster
vorsitzender der innenministerkonferenz
für dieses gespräch